head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts from Ashley
stclair as well as Taylor Hansen these
depict uh we have this from as Ashley
stclair migrants placed next to me on a
premium cabin still has a bag from a
processing center a majority of this
flight is migrants bust in from the
processing CER Center can Delta please
let all of their customers know what
medical screenings are being done for
these migrants illegally crossing our
border from all over the world and being
flown on their flights the big move
right now is to get people to cancel and
boycott Delta and to give Delta the Bud
Light treatment because Delta is
apparently receiving funding from
somewhere to cover the costs and
facilitate human trafficking Delta
Airlines appears to be based on what
we're seeing from Taylor Hansen and Ash
stclair Delta Airlines appears to be
human trafficking and now the question
is who's paying for it yeah people don't
use Delta I think I think we are the tax
perhaps the tax the boycott is a great
idea I think it's fantastic we've shown
before that we can make this we can
actually get a reaction from these
companies and Corporation so that's
probably the right way to go Taylor
Hansen on Twitter says on X illegal
migrants are littered throughout the
Phoenix airport right now they're
receiving priority boarding and
expedited security many have no idea
where they're going locations include
Charlotte Phil Philadelphia New York
City and Texas multiple had to be
escorted from the women's restroom by
security take a look at this video you
got like eight right in this area yeah
yeah
okay like you guys speak Spanish he's
asking him where they're from saying
he's reporting on the issue and uh
obviously I think he said Mexico Spanish
is very rudimentary but uh there's a
really funny moment where someone from
NBC said when you're just trying to
board a plane but someone accus you of
being a migrant because you you don't
look like them or something like this
Ashley St Clair points out they're
holding processing
packets but NBC these people are evil
this is what they do yeah well they want
to scare everybody who's going to even
question ask the basic question like why
are we let these people into our country
they're going to throw out the you're
racist to get them okay no I'm sorry I'm
not racist like don't please don't
accuse me of being racist again like but
no our country is being invaded it's
right up in your face you're paying for
it yes people need P that being afraid
of being name calleded yeah yeah I feel
like anyone that's in in politics that's
not a progressive leftist like and
that's you know that's not really a
a you know that's not a lot of people
the progress Rive left is they're loud
on the internet but there's not a whole
lot of them but at this point if you're
not a progressive leftist being called
racist should be you know irrelevant to
you because anytime that you do anything
at all that they don't like it doesn't
matter if they can somehow tacitly
accuse you of racism that's what they're
going to do so there's not a whole lot
of point in paying any atten that's
that's our wholeo you kill the language
Hitler makes nothing means Hitler insur
misog none of those mean anything
anymore they just overuse it I mean I
was I've been even complaining about the
when it comes to people using the term
uh um genocide when it comes to the
stuff going on in Gaza because it's not
a genocide if if Israel wanted to
genocide the Palestinians in Gaza they
could literally genocide every single
living human being in Gaza so the idea
that it's a genocide is not I want to go
back to using words the way they should
be used yeah I how we get back to
objective we just have to ignore these
people and for for too long people you
know I talked about this last night at
tpusa I said that for a while I believed
that there was no good and evil I
believed that it was just different
worldviews and that it was subjective
and everyone was trying to do what they
thought was right and you get older and
you start to learn no no there there
there's malicious evil their intention
is harm destruction making your life
worse helping no one that's evil mhm the
the
your your average nihilist that's that
you know doesn't actually that really
believes there is no point to life and
stuff they don't have there's no reason
for them to do anything other than
whatever impulse you know catches their
fancy so you know if you don't believe
in I'm I'm of the opinion that if you
don't believe in some form of higher
power you likely are are going to just
be anilist that thinks that there is no
morality there's no real right or wrong
because everyone's going to die and you
know the heat death of the universe and
all that um and if that's your outlook
on life there's not I mean what's the
real reason what there there's no reason
to say that anything is better than
anything else so why not the you know
why not watch it all burn right it
nihilism increases like the short-term
benefits like that's what will make you
like the most animalistic violent
depraved you know they don't cuz they
don't care about consequences right and
they have no moral Center whatsoever so
you see all of the stuff in the cities
where I remember when I lived in uh in
Brooklyn we would see kids there was a
game they were playing where they were
just pushing old people into buses right
like they'd be waiting at the sidewalk
and just be like it was just a game you
know where in the city in Manhattan
there was like kids just pushing old
people it wasn't just old people but
yeah you had you had that whole wave of
uh The Knockout game yeah yeah just try
and kill somebody yep full force just
attempted murder and and the city lets
them get away with it yeah there's no
meaning they have no meaning for life or
or care for it it's it's true truly sad
yeah if you erode all the morals of the
society and then you take away the
actual laws I mean that's exactly what
happens that's why you have to have some
sort of a moral code with the people in
the society but then you also have to
have laws to to back those up you take
away you take away that you get Anarchy
you get what we have right now I one of
the reasons why I I didn't want to live
in New York anymore I was uh uh on the
other side of the Manhattan Bridge I
lived down Broadway a straight shot I
was hanging out at a company party leave
at like 1:00
a.m. hell hell C
I think they I think they make you use
the app cuz like they don't they don't
want Uber so You' use like an app to
call a green taxi or something and I
tell the guy I just live straight down
Broadway and here's here's the number
and he's like you got it and I half
sleep and then all of a sudden I feel
the car turning and I I'm like hey what
are you doing cuz you cross mhand Bridge
you go straight down Broadway and he's
like oh I'm I'm sorry I'm I'm going he
starts weaving going left and right he's
trying to run run up the meter thinking
I was drunk or not paying attention but
I I don't drink and so I said stop the
car I'm getting out he said no we were
we he was slowing down pulling up to a
light the bill that the so far was like
the meter was like 495 I said stop the
car I'm getting out what are you doing
he says no and then as I feel the car
start to move I pop the door and jump
out and he slams the brakes on comes out
screaming demanding I pay him I called
the police immediately and I'm like I I
I walk into a gas station he comes out
screaming threatening me I called the
police says hey this cab driver was
taking me for a ride he's just screaming
at me by the time the cop by the time
time the cops show up the meter's at 50
bucks and the cops told me if I didn't
pay them the 50 bucks they'd arrest
me Y what ended up happening the cops
took my wallet pulled on my cash out
handed it to the cab driver and then
told me to f off that they helped rob
you that's right I got robbed by the
cops just two lady cops they because the
the cabs are a part of the city's racket
yeah they they pay they pay the city
they don't care mhm that so that guy was
trying to rob me and and the cops show
up with guns and said do it or
else insane yeah I'm I'm glad I'm not in
the city anymore we I mean we we left
when my wife was pregnant with our first
and it was just getting so depraved and
I she was working in the city and I was
working in the city or just outside of
the city so sometimes she have to take
the subway without me which was
terrifying right and sometimes you take
a taxi but sometimes you take the subway
and there was like guys like screaming
about chopping your head off you know
and uh and then no one and then no one
doing anything yeah like no one cared
they just tune out like whatever like
yep we're getting out of this place it's
totally insane it's reminding me of the
70s in the city that's what I would hear
from my family who were cops or
firefighters in New York and it not just
you know it's not unique to New York but
that's how it was for sure in the 70s
you know that was like the summer of
burkowitz but like also fires all the
time and complete destruction so that
was the crazy part for me that the Riots
of 2020 when Portland like lit up you
had a lot of people that were on the
periphery of that were like well you
know this isn't really a bad thing they
were defending it I'm like no no guys
this this is horrible like they're yeah
but racism's also really bad like no
one's talking about race if you believe
this has anything to do with race I
don't know what to tell you they're
destroying the entire city and they're
not going to stop and like they
literally haven't in Portland but you do
get this I don't know if some of it's
just people being complacent them hoping
that things are going to change but not
wanting to take action but you also do
get this fear I think of a lot of people
that they don't want to be called like
if you say that hey we're doing this for
racial Justice if you're we're opening
the borders for racial Justice like then
all the sudden like if you push back on
that they're going to call you a racist
and that's that's really powerful I
think for a lot of people makes a lot of
people live in fear I think all that CRT
stuff is all like tendrils of Marxism
because they're doing Marxist stuff
power it's power plays to take your
power but they're going to make you
afraid of talking out against it and
like and you just gave me another PTSD
flashback of lockdowns when I don't know
how it was by you but in New York they
just like let loose everyone in the
prisons for lockdowns they're just like
yeah it was like Arkham you know they
like I just go home and then crime went
crazy you know there was some obviously
some recidivism but I don't know how it
was like we're still having major issues
in Washington state with them opening up
the prisons AG Ferguson who's now
running to be our next Governor
unfortunately he's had a a program where
he's letting violent sex offenders out
and then putting them into communities
into privately contracted houses where
these people are not guarded whatsoever
they're saying they're doing it to you
know reduce the the population in the
prison but they're not choosing
nonviolent offenders the most of most
the people they're releasing are violent
sex offenders the only reason some of
it's gotten stopped is because
individual citizens in small towns have
said hey why is private company buying
up a five-bedroom house you know in
rural thiron County and Washington State
but that's the Democrats I I say they're
the party of open borders and open
prisons to anarcho and I I agree in
prison reform but not like that right
exactly nonviolent prisoners sure but
you lock up the violent sex offenders y
Common Sense thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net MERS only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time